الصور المباشره من باريس الاحتجاجات
الحاشده ضد اصلاحات اقترحها رئيس امام
ريال ماكو وعلى راسها رفع سن التقاعد بين
62 عاما الى 64 عاما فلنع
لمزيد من التفاصيل معنا من باريس مراسل
العربيه فادي دهوك فادي يعني ابرز المطالب
الذي حملها المتظاهرين التي اصبحت معروفه
ولكن كيف تتعاطى هناك الحكومه مع هذه
المطالب وما هي خريطه التظاهرات
مساء الخير ليال المتظاهرون كما ذكرتيهم
لطالبون او يحتجون على رفع سن التقاعد الى
64 عاما لكن الحكومه ما تزال مسرع على هذه
المساله وتقول ان لا مفاوضات حول ذلك ان
هناك تصريحات لرئيسه الوزراء اليزا بيتبول
قالت انها همم منفتحه على نقاش بعض النقاط
في مشروع هذا القرار لكن مساله رفع سن
التقاعد هي مساله غير قابله للنقاش وان
الحكومه ستسير بها حتى النهايه التظاهره
كما ترون هناك حدود غفيره جدا تشارك فيها
الان في العاصمه باريس كان من المتوقع ان
تخرج تظاهرات همم باعداد مليونيه في مختلف
انحاء فرنسا بيحسب وثيقه للاستخبارات
الفرنسيه ذكرت انها توقعات تشير الى ان
نحو مليون ومئتين الفرنسي ينزلون الى
الشوارع اليوم للتظاهر حتى الان الاعداد
في العاصمه باريس بحسب ما ذكرت النقابات
هي 500,000 متظاهر الان هم يسيرون باتجاه
النقطه الاخيره لهذه التظاهره بالقرب من
ساحه ان فاليد وهي منطقه تشهد عدد كبير من
المقرات الحكوميه الحساسه خصوصا وزاره
الدفاع وايضا ما قر الحكومه طبعا هذا هذه
التظاهرات والاضراب ياتي بدعوه من ثمان
نقابات للعمال ولكن ايضا بدعم من كافه
احزاب اليسار الفرنسي التي دعت الى هذا
اليوم هناك سيكون تصعيد جديد في السادس من
فبراير المقبل موعد جديد للتظاهر الاضراب
سيكون هناك اضراب لمده ثلاثه ايام ياتي
بالتزامن مع موعد تقديم مشروع القرار الى
البرلمان طبعا الاضراب اليوم همم شله حركه
النقل في فرنسا لان قطاع النقل شارك فيه
بشكل كبير جدا همم
وتسبب ايضا الاضراب على مستوى فرنسا في
تعطيل انتاج الكهرباء
والمدارس وايضا عدد كبير من المؤسسات 40%
من موظفي شركه الكهرباء الوطنيه اودي
افعلوا انهم يشاركون في هذا الاضراب 36%
ايضا من قطاع السكك الحديديه وما بين 70%
الى 100% من موظفي حقول النفط في شركه
توتال اعلنوا انهم يشاركون في هذا الاضراب
ايضا طبعا المعارضه تحاول تعطيل هذا
المشروع من خلال انها قدمت اكثر من سبعه
الى التعذيب المشروع القانون في محاوله
لقاء مساره عبر البرلمان
وهناك همم
واستمرار
همم
لا يمكن ان نسمع رساله بشكل واضح ساعود
واذاكر مشاهدينا بابرز مطالب المتظاهرين
في فرنسا طبعا هي اضرابات ضد الاصلاحات
التي اقترحها الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكو
على راسها طبعا رفع سن التقاعد من 62 عاما
الى 64 عاما النقابات هناك تعمل ان تكون
تظاهرات اليوم التظاهرات التي حصلت
الاسبوع او ال في 10 ايام الماضيه
وتظاهرات التي ستحصل بالايام الماضيه بنفس
الزخم التي شهدته احتجاجات ما سميه
بالخميس الاسود في ال 19 طبعا من هذا
الشهر هذا وتسببت اليوم هذه اتطهرات بشلل
على مختلف المستويات من المدارس النقل
العام الاشغال في العاصمه الفرنسيه وفي
مناطق